speaking of the Quran here.
that the Quran
is descri
bed with these two
descriptions. The first
description is that it is a
remembrance. The second
description is that it is
blessed. Remembrance, what it
is, what is it a remembrance of
scholars of Islam tell us that
the Quran is referred to as
remembrance Because it reminds
the person of what is innately
instilled of disposition when a
person is born. The football.
What a person is born upon.
Knowing that Allah is one.
Knowing that there cannot be
more than one. Knowing that one
plus one equals two. Knowing
that the religion be that only
Allah should be worshiped alone
without any partners. This
Quran taps back into that
original disposition
disposition, excuse me, that we
were born upon. prophet
mentions The narration
collected by Bukhari, a Muslim.
He said, every child is born
upon this disposition, the
original
and it is the parents of the
child that then distort this
disposition and dilute it
and veer the child off into
Christianity, Judaism,
etcetera. So, when a poor
person is born, they are born
knowing these these original
things that they were created
by Allah, loan without any
partners, that's only Allah is
worthy of worship, that there
is only one creator, etcetera.
and it is their parents who
subsequently distort and defile
this fitra. and so, this Quran
refers
back to that this Quran
is a remembrance because it
reminds us of where we
originally came from. Our
original disposition. It ties
back into our original state of
being. our original state of
being is the worship of Allah
alone without any partners. The
veneration of truth the
dispraise of falsehood, these
kinds of qualities. It is a
reminder and a remembrance of
that. He also described it as
being blessed. What does that
mean? Blessed. Mubarak. This is
taken from a root word in the
Arabic language. Which is
comprised of three letters.
Bah, rah, ka, calf, and these
letters articulate immensity
and they articulate remnants.
They articulate immensity and
they articulate remnants. But
when we say a broke or Ramadan
Mubarak, right? We say these
things. What this articulates
in the Arabic language is an
abundance of good that is
remnant. That remains. This is
why the Arabs would refer to a
lake as a Bitica. Dedicate
because it is a lot of good
water that is remnant. It stays
there. Likewise, they refer to
a camel when it sits, when it
lays down, they call this
action
because it is much good that is
remnant and stable. Oh Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala describes
this Quran as Mubarak. As a
book which has been made
blessed. Has been made an
abundance of remnant good. That
Allah has sent down to us. How
then may we reject such a gift
from Allah. Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala after mentioning all of
this introduction. The past
50 verses of this chapter. The
first 50 verses are all
essentially an introduction.
And all essentially the
principles and the foundations
of religion and Islam. And
call of all the prophets and
messengers. This is all we've
been dealing with in the first
fifty verses of this chapter.
Now, the chapter is going to
take a different turn. Now, the
chapter is going to go into
examples of the prophet's
legacy and the messenger's
legacy and we're going to have
a very specific amount of
prophets that are mentioned. We
have prophets and messengers
who have different journeys.
Some of them were sent to
people who fundamentally
disbelieved in them. Meaning,
people that worshiped idols
that they were sent to. We have
a group. We have prophets that
were sent to a people that
worshiped the same creator and
they are Muslim but they came
as revivers of of that
religion. We have other
prophets that may not have been
sent to anyone. We have
prophets whom their people
became Muslim. We have prophets
whom their people did not. We
have prophets who were sent to
people whom their was disturbed
and distorted. the people
of Lut that will be mentioned
this chapter So, not only does
Allah mention the most
important and critical prophets
and messengers and a bit of
their story, but he mentions a
very specific group of prophets
and messengers. Each of which
represents a very unique aspect
of what the prophets and
messengers came to teach their
people. Right? if you could
imagine with me here that each
one of these prophets that we
are going to mention in this
chapter, we're going to have
Ibrahim, Luut, Noor, Dawood,
Suleiman, a Europe, known
Zacharia, Yahia, all of their,
all of them are mentioned. Now,
before we mention them, imagine
with me that each one of these
prophets and messengers,
represents different aspects of
prophethood, right? So, every
one of these prophets and
messengers came with everything
else that the prophets and
messengers before him and after
him came with, essentially. But
some of them came with more
pronounced aspects than others.
So, for instance, all of the
prophets and messengers came
with worship Allah alone
without any partners. But
Ibrahim Alaihi Salam, that was
more pronounced in his life
than the other aspects. All of
the prophets and messengers
came with the
the announcement of sexual
perversion that damages the
fitra. However, and his
prophethood is more pronounced
in that aspect, right? All of
the prophets and messengers,
saved all of the messengers
were saved from their people's
attempts to harm them, to kill
them. However, Noah Alaihi
Salam, that aspect of his life
was more pronounced than other
prophets. Do you get where I'm
going at here with this? What I
mean is that, everyone of these
prophets and messengers has an
element of what was mentioned
in another prophet and
messenger. In this chapter
However, Tahid is mentioned, we
think of Ibrahim because that
was more pronounced in his
legacy. When we think about
being saved from saved and
delivered by Allah, we think of
all the messengers were but
Noah Alaihi Salam, that is more
pronounced and more personified
in his life, right? When we
think about dealing with a
damaged fitr and sexual
perversion We think of because
he dealt with that the most.
Other prophets and messengers,
all of them dealt with that to
some degree. But that issue was
more pronounced in his, in his
legacy, etcetera. So all of
these prophets, all of their
stories that we are going to
read here, all of these
stories, really describe one
prophethood. They all describe
one prophethood. They all
describe another angle of of
prophethood. That they all
have. The prophet he mentions
this very clearly in Sahih Al
Bukhari. He says, the parable,
the example of me and the
prophets who have preceded me
is that of a mason who
built a palace. And left one
brick unlaid. The whole palace
is built. Everything is done
but there's just one missing
brick. He said and so people
would come and marvel at how
wondrous this palace was and
great this palace was and they
would each say, this palace is
perfect essentially if the
mason would only lay that final
brick. So, he said, I am that
final brick. There is no profit
after me. What does this mean?
Well, if we look at the nature
of a building, we see that. if
If one wall of the building
consists of bricks, that is all
part of the same building but
it's a different part of the
same building. One is on the
east side, one is on the left,
on the west side. If we were to
have, for instance, four or
five people go outside of the
masjid right now. And each
person described to us what
they see. Right? Would they not
all be describing the same
building? Yeah, but they're
they descriptions would be very
different, right? Because
they're describing different
aspects of the same building.
Likewise, if we told them turn
around and describe the
neighborhood, would they not
all describe the same
neighborhood? Yes, but they're
going, their descriptions are
going to vary because they're
looking at the neighborhood
from a different angle. This is
essentially prophethood,
messengership. They're all
describing the same house, the
same temple of worship, the
same masjid of Allah, the same
house of Allah. Just some of
them happened to be on the
corner. of the Masjid. Some may
be on the west wall, some may
be on the eastern wall. So,
their description while all of
it being part of the same
building, their description
might be more pronounced at one
part of the building than
another. And likewise, all of
the elements that we are going
to see. And these prophets and
messengers, we are going to
find in the prophet Muhammad
And we are going to find a bit
of everyone's story in the
story of the prophet
[Arabic recitation]